Southern California has just undergone a
record 87 straight days of smog did you
know that 87 - have you noticed that 87
straight days of smog yeah it's but yeah
it's rough in fact the smog is so bad
here people in the audience tonight
think they're at a taping of Ellen they
they're like let me like gonna dance
with us that explains the dancing that
explains what else is going to of course
the big story a second woman has come
forward to accuse Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh of sexual misconduct
yeah for those of you keeping track 13
Moore and Cavanaugh can run for
president and I know you heard this in a
new interview with Fox News Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh said he
was a virgin in high school and for many
years thereafter yes so now President
Trump is calling on him to withdraw
the hell you're talking about lost his
virginity at 51 I'm told he beat my
record there's a rumor that Assistant
Attorney General rod Rosenstein wants to
declare president Trump unfit for office
yeah right now right now all Rosenstein
has to go on is everything Trump has
said or done for the past two years
that's always God but he's gonna wait
here's an interesting story gay sex
that's got your attention gay sex is no
longer illegal in the island nation of
Trinidad and Tobago in fact last night
Trinidad moved in with Tobago
[Applause]
that was stupid glad I told you that
actress Ellen Pompeo hinted that two
years from now she may leave Grey's
Anatomy yeah when they heard this fans
of Grey's Anatomy said week that show is
still on is that and those are fans
that's why that's why that jokes funny
those are fans it's true right Weight
Watchers announced its changing its name
yep they've changed their name to screw
it have the fudge
[Applause]
you